let's see where we're at in the
prediction market after all this Kevin
McCarthy is the favorite to win I bought
800 shares in Jim Jordan and I'm losing
all my money
because I was just like
it's not so much about thinking Jim
Jordan's gonna win but that the here's
how the prediction Market works you buy
a share in Jim Jordan for six cents if
something happens that makes it seem
like he might win he'll go up to like 15
cents and then you can sell the share
and make money off of it
that's how buying shares works I don't I
don't think it's going to be Kevin
McCarthy I mean I think there's a strong
chance it it it will be but I'm not
entirely convinced this is an alternate
timeline so Trump 100 could be coming
because everything that has existed I
mean 100 somebody I fully believe
someone time traveled stepped on a
butterfly and or a bug and what we're
living is 100 an alternate timeline I'm
a big Back to the Future guy and uh 100
I would I'm not endorsing this by any
means but if I had to put my money on
Trump if uh Rachel if you're listening
can you put some money on Donald Trump